bonjour à tous nous sommes très heureux
de vous retrouver ce matin pour cette
année qui s'annonce passionnante on
voulait avant de commencer et de passer
la parole annie vous présentait
justement annie genevard on est très
heureux qu'elle nous rejoigne dans
l'équipe des porte parole avec cette
double expérience à la fois d'élu local
en tant que maire et puis de
parlementaire avec un certain nombre de
compétences et une passion particulière
pour toutes les questions liées à
l'éducation et l'enseignement supérieur
puisque elle n'y est délégué national au
sein des républicains pour l'ensemble de
ses missions
et puis elle connaît très bien les élus
locaux
moi je le dis en tant que maire d'une
commune rurale puisque annie et
vice-présidente aussi de la mf donc nous
lui passons avec philippe et valérie
avec grand plaisir la parole et elle
sera avec nous tous les mardis pour
assurer ce point presse
merci guillaume bonjour à tous alors on
m'a chargé pour mon baptême du feu de
vous présenter l'agenda donc je vais
commencer par cela si vous voulez bien
pour la semaine du 5 au 11 septembre
nous avons ce matin à ce point presse
hebdomadaire auquel je participerai
désormais et puis ce soir le bureau
politique nous reprenons nos travaux
après l'interruption estivale le jeudi 8
septembre à 18 heures nous aurons un
meeting départemental de notre président
avec notre président laurent wauquiez à
guilherand granges le samedi 10
septembre à 13 heures aura lieu le
banquet des républicains maritime en
présence de notre président laurent
wauquiez et puis le lendemain dimanche
11 septembre à midi la fête
départementale de charente se déroulera
en présence de notre secrétaire général
eric woerth
voilà donc pour la semaine qui vient
voilà alors je voulais vous dire tout
d'abord quelques mots sur ma présence le
président laurent wauquiez a souhaité
que l'équipe des porte paroles reflètent
la diversité de notre mouvement et
chacun connaît mon engagement aux côtés
de françois fillon
j'ai toujours dit que j'étais fidèle à
françois fillon et loyal avec le
président de notre mouvement c'était
nicolas sarkozy c'est aujourd'hui
laurent wauquiez c'est toujours ma ligne
de conduite je n'en déroge pas et donc
laurent a souhaité que et bien une
représentation diversifiée des porte
paroles puissent témoigner ainsi de son
souci d'impartialité
alors le premier sujet que nous allons
aborder
c'est un sujet qui a été très débattues
ces dernières heures
ils concernent évidemment nicolas
sarkozy plusieurs plusieurs remarques
que je voudrais faire à ce sujet tout
d'abord il y as je crois une légitime
interrogation sur la concomitance entre
le premier jour du procès de jérôme
cahuzac et la sphère du dépassement des
comptes de campagne car c'est bien de
cela que nous parlons le dépassement des
comptes de campagne c'est le motif pour
lequel nicolas sarkozy a été mis en
examen et on voit qu'il est bon tout de
même de rappeler les faits alors des
vraies questions demeurent sur la
précipitation le délai
n'était pas encore abouti le motif qui
ne correspond pas à la mise en examen et
puis une interrogation aussi sur
l'articulation avec la décision du
conseil constitutionnel en tout état de
cause il n'est jamais bon lorsque la
justice est suspecté de partialité il ya
quelques principes fondamentaux qui
fondent notre droit c'est l'indépendance
de la justice et la présomption
d'innocence c'est le secret de
l'instruction voilà quelques principes
qu'il est bon tout de même de rappeler
et généralement on évite la le que le
calendrier judiciaire et le calendrier
politique ne se percutent
cela étant dit la justice doit faire son
travail
elle le fera et j'espère qu'elle
clarifiera le plus rapidement possible
les choses voilà ce que je souhaitais
vous dire s'agissant de cette affaire
peut-être pendant que j'ai la parole un
point sur lequel j'aimerais attirer
votre attention mesdames et messieurs
les journalistes c'est une semaine un
peu particulière pour l'éducation
puisque nous avons deux grèves de grève
qui s'annonce une qui vient d'avoir lieu
c'est la grève des animateurs scolaire
qui
et on en charge les ce qui résulte de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires c'est à
dire les temps d'accueil périscolaire et
puis la grève des enseignants la suite
de la réforme du collège donc deux
réformes majeures du quinquennat en
matière éducative sont remis en cause
cette année par ces deux grèves
je trouve que ça en dit long de l'échec
du gouvernement aussi en la matière
voilà merci merci annie bonjour à toutes
et à tous de points en ce qui me
concerne la sphère cahuzac et puis après
le drame de la jungle de calais la
sphère cahuzac ne nous posons nous ici
les républicains un certain nombre de
questions d'où nous souhaiterions
qu'elles trouvent réellement des
réponses il n'y a pas que nous si on
écoute un petit peu l'ensemble des
matinales de 2 ce matin monsieur le
premier ministre ce matin a dit qu'il
était écoeurée par cette affaire sent
qu'il manque nous pouvons comprendre
certainement mais ce n'est qu'un
sentiment
or la politique et le droit ne sont pas
des sentiments
ils recherchent les faits est ce qui
nous intéresse nous c'est effectivement
la vérité des faits si on écoute
monsieur bart et qui est intervenu ce
matin chez thomas sotto il ya quand même
des questions
c'est lui qui a fait un travail le plus
fouillés en la matière il ya des
questions qui se posent monsieur barré
et lui indique que sa famille politique
à monsieur cahuzac savait et monsieur
calzia que aux relevés d'audience qui a
pu être fait hier indique s'il ne
s'était pas senti du sang tu senti
excusez-moi soutenu ne serait pas allé
aussi loin dans le mensonge
le support est dit que sa famille
politique savait lui manifestement le
dit également question que szavay qui au
niveau et quoi au niveau du parti
socialiste deuxième question quand s'est
arrêtée ce financement commence à en
voir un petit peu les contours
mais quand cela s'est il arrêté
précisément troisième question cela a
commencé autour des années 90 si on en
croit monsieur cahuzac
je vous avoue que croire monsieur
cahuzac
est un vrai credo mais il faut néanmoins
en la matière écouter ce qu'il dit et
les juges pourront disperser le mauvais
grain de l'ivraie
ça aurait commencé dans les années 90 si
on en croit monsieur cahuzac
c'est monsieur rocard qui
malheureusement n'est plus là pour dire
le contraire aurait était le
bénéficiaire supputer puisque lui-même
ne le savais pas ça est un peu compliqué
de cette ouverture de compte si on
regarde cliniquement les choses dans les
années 90 autour de michel rocard qui
avait t-il dans cette garde rapprochée
importante en qui il avait confiance
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de médias
ne se lasse pas de laisser un certain
nombre de photos apparaître sur cette
garde rapprochée
il y avait monsieur fuchs il y avait
monsieur colmou il y avait monsieur
valls et d'autres et vous aussi monsieur
cambadélis
il avait aussi monsieur mélenchon ils
ont eu des chemins qui ont dérivé après
monsieur mélenchon nous nous
interrogeons aujourd'hui mais ce que
nous et conseiller politique de manuel
valls
hier il était chef de cabinet de
monsieur rocard est ce un hasard s un
lien y at il quelque chose ce sont des
interrogations
nous portons des interrogations ces
interrogations aujourd'hui elles sont
fortes puisque est la tienne le plus
haut sommet de l'état
il est absolument nécessaire que ce
désastre absolu
quelle est l affaire cahuzac je vous
rappelle que cet homme a menti devant
les français a menti devant la
représentation nationale
il dit qu'il l'a fait pour un membre de
sa famille politique
l'at-il fait pour plusieurs membres de
sa famille politique et pour financer
exactement quoi évidemment les
républicains demandent des réponses
monsieur cahuzac a dit hier qu'il y
avait une personne qui savait mais qui
était vivante
donc il ne voulait pas la citer nous
voulons savoir les français doivent
savoir la justice le dira certainement
et je pense que le parti socialiste est
toute personne qui aurait des
informations seraient bien fondé à
pouvoir d indiqué
autre sujet plus que préoccupant pour
l'ensemble des habitants du calaisis des
habitants des hauts de france et
l'ensemble des français
la jungle de calais un premier chiffre
en 2012 ce lieu était occupé par 900
migrants
aujourd'hui les chiffres de la police
raisons très précises indiquent qu'ils
sont neuf mille dix fois plus est ce que
cela est en corrélation avec la baisse
des reconduites à la frontière qu'on
nous a annoncé la semaine dernière très
certainement mais on voit qu'en la
matière le gouvernement et
singulièrement monsieur monsieur
cazeneuve ne font pas leur travail
ces personnes qui sont dans des
situations qui sont parfaitement
inacceptable du point de vue de leur
logement du point de vue de leurs droits
mais produit et demande la violence
insoutenable qui s'y déroulent veulent
aller en angleterre il ne veulent
absolument pas rester en france
monsieur cazeneuve indique que la jungle
va être démantelés camps surtout comment
nous refusons nous les républicains que
le gouvernement fasse une espèce de
dispersion de l'ensemble des migrants
sur l'ensemble du territoire
or nous voyons bien que la tentation est
grande
d'envoyer un petit peu dans la creuse
est un petit peu en corrèze peut-être
pas encore s
les migrants qui ne seraient plus les
bienvenus à calais nous nous y refusons
parfaitement c'est pourquoi nous
demandons au gouvernement quel est son
plan
comment va-t-il faire pour que et bien
il n'y est pas renvoi de ces populations
ailleurs je rappelle non plus n'est pas
le souhait ces populations qui elle
souhaite aller en angleterre
c'est pour cela qu'il faut absolument
revoir le partenariat que nous avons
avec les onglets en la matière qui
doivent prendre leurs responsabilités
pardon c'est une question qui est
d'importance et c'est qu'une question
sur laquelle nous reviendrons
systématiquement afin d'avoir les
réponses qui aujourd'hui pour le moins
sont évanescente
merci valérie dans bâle dans le
prolongement de ce que tu évoques et de
ce que nous évoquions dès ce matin nous
nous voulions dénoncer avec force à la
suite encore plus particulièrement des
révélations du figaro ce matin ce qui
s'est passé la prison denis dans le val
d'oise
ces derniers jours qui démontre une fois
de plus que la puissance publique est
devenue l'impuissance publique que le
pouvoir n'a plus le pouvoir car on se
demande bien où sont passés messieurs
cazeneuve et urvoas sur une question
aussi importante c'est d'ailleurs la
même réflexion que tu faisais sur la
question de calais et nous voyons
aujourd'hui et ce ne sont pas simplement
les syndicats pénitentiaires qui
l'évoquent que les prisons françaises
sont devenues une véritable poudrière
hier soir d'ailleurs le parquet a été
saisi le parquet antiterroriste
parce que tout laisse à croire à l'heure
où nous parlons chaos ni s'est déroulée
une mutinerie d'une gravité
exceptionnelle à vocation terroriste
organisée par plusieurs détenus dans un
centre dit de déradicalisation dans
lequel nous apprenons ce matin que les
contribuables français financent pour
ces terroristes tous ces apprentis
terroristes des cours de des scream des
massages réalisé par des masseurs ou des
kinésithérapeutes
on voit bien le décalage incroyable
fossé l'océan qui est en train de
s'agrandir entre la tante de nos
compatriotes sur le rétablissement de
l'autorité de l'état et une politique
nationale et gouvernementale fondée sur
le laxisme la capitulation et
l'aveuglément et donc nous demandons au
nom des républicains au nom de laurent
wauquiez au nom toute notre famille
politique des comptes au gouvernement
pour comprendre précisément ce qui s'est
passé dans cette prison où je vous
rappelle
surveillant a été très gravement blessé
avec des tentatives
dégorgement une mise en scène vient
d'être identifiée avec des liens descend
sur les murs des débuts de prière on
voit bien que tout semble mener à une
volonté d'appliquer l'une des demandes
par vidéo de l'état islamique et de
dèche d'assassiner sur le territoire
national des représentants de
l'administration pénitentiaire comme
c'est le cas hélas pour d'autres
représentants de l'état et pour des
citoyens anonymes
il est donc temps que le gouvernement et
que l'autorité de l'état soient
rétablies avec la fermeté la plus
impitoyable
la seule politique possible pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
plutôt que de nous épuiser avec des
écrans de fumée judiciaires ou des
fausses promesses
c'est désormais de reconnaître que la
maison france brûle que les prisons
brûle que les prisons sont devenues des
des lieux et là où le radicalisme
progresse et prospère et donc nous
attendons désormais et de manière
absolue des actes et des décisions
fortes
nous ne voulons plus d'un mise de
l'intérieur ou d'un biseau la justice
qui vient commenter bavarde et analyser
la télévision ces phénomènes qui
exaspère nos compatriotes nous attendons
des actes forts de la part du
gouvernement de la france
merci sur l'actualité européenne
peut-être juste avant de parler de
l'actualité européenne je rebondis sur
ce que tu viens de dire
nous souhaitons que le gouvernement
mettre fin à ce scandale qui fait que
sur internet
l'accès au journal de al qaida d'un côté
l'accès au journal de l'état islamique
de l'autre est totalement disponible est
libre en première page de google
pas besoin d'être un spécialiste de la
recherche sur internet
n'importe qui peut lire ses écrits et
nous ne comprenons pas que le
gouvernement qui prétend agir
au bout de plusieurs mois n'est toujours
pas réglé cette question absolument
ahurissante par l'actualité européenne
oui j'ai un gros dossier donc je vous
épargne et j'ai pas tout tout tout vous
lire elle est très riche
le tt ip le break si des travailleurs
détachés apple les accords du touquet la
réunification de chypre où le
gouvernement espagnol
je vais vous parler de la crise du lait
qui est une question qui est européenne
qui
si française bien entendu je parle sous
ton contrôle toi qui connais
parfaitement ces questions comme vous le
savez la crise du lait était majeure les
agriculteurs française et
particulièrement les métiers sont en
train de mourir sans que le gouvernement
ne semble s'émouvoir de cette affaire
nous en avons parlé à la conférence de
presse la semaine dernière et depuis la
semaine dernière stéphane le foll a
annoncé une enveloppe de 50 millions
d'euros pour aider les producteurs à
baisser leur production
en réalité non seulement cette somme est
absolument ridicule mais surtout cette
somme ne servira à rien si nous arrivons
nous abaisser notre production mais que
les autres pays européens augmentent
leur production
or c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer d'autres pays européens
actuellement augmentent leur production
et c'est une des sources des mots et
maïque ce que vivent nos agriculteurs
actuellement et donc ce que nous
demandons à stéphane le foll est assez
simple c'est de prendre son bâton de
pèlerin et de faire le tour des
capitales européennes pour trouver un
accord la france l'agriculture française
ne peut être de défendu que si le
ministre de l'agriculture lui même a
compris que la pac était une politique
européenne commune et pas simplement à
déclinaison nationale
nous souhaitons que soient mises en
place des mécanismes de limitation de la
surproduction laitière insiste la mise
en place d'un système d'assurance de
fonds mutuels pour garantir les
agriculteurs en cas de crise comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui
nous souhaitons une restructuration des
filières avec une contractualisation
entre les différents acteurs pour jouer
un airbag face aux diminutions de prix
puisque vous savez que le prix du lait
baisse alors que
baez payé au producteur est il augmente
d'ailleurs chez le consommateur on
considère que prix d'un litre de lait
que vous achetiez dans votre dans votre
boutique et bien et passer en gros le
producteur en bénéficient à hauteur de
35% aujourd'hui alors qu'il ya trois ans
il tirait 40 % du prix de vente donc on
voit bien que la part de lait des
producteurs c'est absolument effondré
nous voulons aussi une transparence des
prix qui n'est pas suffisante
actuellement pour analyser les choses et
enfin nous voulons une réforme profonde
du droit de la concurrence européenne le
droit de la concurrence européenne
interdit les accords entre producteurs
interdit d'accord en particulier pour
constituer des stocks
nous souhaitons que cette affaire là
soit mise sur le bureau du conseil d'une
manière urgente
il en va de l'existence même de la
filière laitière française et européenne
nous ne voulons pas et nous ne
laisserons pas aux républicains les
laitiers mourir en france alors que le
gouvernement semble totalement
désintéressé sur les autres questions
européennes
je répondrai avec plaisir à vos
questions si vous en avez